welcome back to CBS this morning
Saturday we begin this half-hour with
concerns about how the corona virus may
affect our nation's blood supply as more
people are choosing to avoid gatherings
blood drives around the nation are being
canceled as Chris Martinez reports the
Red Cross says they need healthy
eligible people to donate so we don't
see shortages
Carlton Schroeder donates blood once
every two months it's not only to help
others but also his own health the
doctor wanted me to drop a pint of blood
because I have hemoglobin the Red Cross
says donations like Carlton's are vital
now more than ever as coronavirus
worries rise blood drives around the
nation are being canceled especially in
states with large outbreaks patients are
counting on us across the country Red
Cross vice president Paul Sullivan says
blood banks are asking healthy people to
donate and maintain the blood supply
whether it's people in emergency
situations whether it's car accidents
people giving birth blood is a vital
part of our health care system and we
need to make sure that we have it
available for the patients to help keep
donors safe the Red Cross is now taking
everyone's temperature when they walk in
the door and when they undergo a private
health screening the center's and
equipment are also regularly disinfected
from top to bottom the Red Cross is also
screening their own staff taking every
employee's temperature when they arrive
at work as far as the blood supply the
organization says at this point there's
no evidence corona virus can be spread
through blood Carlton says donating now
is a no brainer blood is needed and
blood so he hopes more donors come
forward to help Chris Martinez CBS News
Pasadena California
the other no-brainer would be if you're
not feeling well yeah yeah
good news you get cookie and juice
usually after yeah I love that he's the
one that has the high hemoglobin but if
you are and able please do so yeah
absolutely